hello everyone so today we're going to
talk about unit testing for Deva
scientists and as we just said my name
is Hanna I'm from Chicago I work at
shopper in our shop Brenner is a
chicago-based company ecommerce company
we like to refer to ourselves as the
Amazon Prime for everyone else so we
work with a network of partners of
retail partners to whom we provide a
bunch of kind of data-driven tools for
to like help them better connect with
their customers and then we have a
membership base that we provide sweet
benefits like these like free two-day
shipping and free returns and deals
across this really broad network of
partners despite our name we don't
actually do any of the delivery or
logistics so we do particularly on the
data science team we spend a ton of time
digging into this really rich really
cross network data set which is a lot of
fun if you're interested in shopping I
have a bunch of free membership cards
you should come see me after the stock
all right so we're gonna talk about unit
testing today everybody's super excited
right you know testing is so much fun I
hope you're as excited is this cat I
like cats there are a lot of cats in
this talk and all of the there's gonna
be a bunch of code examples all the code
examples are in a github repo that I
will share at the end and these slides
will also be in that rebuilding later
today so testing has a whole bunch of
jargon that if you're not in software
engineering you may not be super
familiar with these are some of the
terms today we are just going to worry
about unit testing so there's all other
types of testing that we're gonna put to
the side we're gonna talk about unit
testing so unit testing is testing a
single piece of code in an isolated
context so we're not gonna worry about
how everything please together but we're
gonna make sure that each piece is doing
what we wanted to be doing
well twisted code has a bunch of
benefits it's really nice to work at a
code base that has a lot of good unit
tests it makes you it makes it super
easy to find bugs just very nice always
better to find them earlier rather than
later it makes it much easier to aerate
you're not scared to make changes in a
code base that has really good tests
because if you break something you're
gonna know and you're gonna get to make
conscious choices about what to do about
that it makes it much easier to debug
things if something goes wrong and you
don't know what's happening you have
this nice suite of like isolated pieces
that tells you where exactly something
work and it pushes you to actually
design better code so if you're writing
tests for something and it's really hard
to isolate pieces and it doesn't all fit
together that's often a clue that your
code is not structured as well as it
could be
and if you write code with the knowledge
in mind that you're going to be writing
tests for it you will write cleaner code
but basically unit tests give you
confidence that your code does what you
think it does my favorite and least
favorite thing about computers so they
always do exactly what you tell them to
this is a great way to make sure that
what you're telling them is what you
think you're telling them oh so these
all seem pretty nice so why doesn't
everybody write a whole bunch of unit
tests we just list it off a bunch of
great benefits but it's Peeta scientists
I bet many of you in the room have
written a fair amount of code and not
unit tested it so why not
learning to write good tests is
definitely an investment so it takes
time to learn to do it well and it takes
time to actually do it but if you're
ever gonna have to maintain the packages
that you write which if you want them to
be used anywhere you're gonna have to
maintain them means that this investment
investment is worthwhile and you will
gain the benefits over time of having
good test Suites built out another kind
of tricky part as data scientists is
that data science work follows a lot of
different patterns than pure software
engineering does so when I first started
as a data scientist I was coming out of
academia and I had vaguely heard of a
lot of these terms before but I never
actually written a unit test and I think
that's pretty common I think a lot of us
come the APIs like this is awesome field
and that it draws people from a really
wide breadth of fields many of them
academic and many of them not super
well-versed in this kind of software
engineering core skills that the people
who maintain your websites at companies
and whatnot are so as I started reaching
out and trying to learn how to do this
better I kept coming up with there's a
super wide variety of resources I kept
coming up with well-written blog posts
and example sets and all of this but
they were all tailored to a slightly
different approach than all of the code
that I was trying to write and thus all
the code that I was trying to test so
I'm here today to talk about
specifically like the patterns that data
scientists work with a lot and how we
can test them well so in theory we have
workflows that look something like this
you're eating a bunch of data we build a
bunch of features we build a bunch of
models we hand results off to someone we
evaluate the results do some stuff at
the end looks pretty straightforward but
in practice particularly as you move
towards kind of production systems you
know things that look more like this
this is for example what a lot of our
workflows look like a JEP retur where
you have a bunch of pieces and are
playing you're reading data in you're
writing it out you're calling api's
you've gotten on non-deterministic
things in there this quickly gets
overwhelming and this makes you just not
want to write tests at all but that is a
bad idea and you will regret it later so
why do we start so when you guys start
writing unit tests whether you're
working with a code base that is mature
and in existence but has never been unit
tested or you're starting to write a new
package from scratch you want to start
really small you want to start with a
particular specific functionality that
you want to verify is actually happening
the way you think it is you want to use
all the available tools many of which
were going to talk about in a moment to
get everything else out of the way unit
testing is all about isolation it's all
about taking this one defined
functionality and ignoring everything
else and saying is this piece working
the way I think it is and then you do
that for all of your pieces eventually
and you've got to gain a lot of
confidence in what's happening overall
if you have an existing code base don't
try to write tests for it all at once
you will get overwhelmed it will be
frustrating and you will give up and
that's really unfortunate you really
need to start small you say okay we on
the data science team at shop Runner we
have only had a data science team for a
couple of years so we've worked mostly
with new libraries that we've written
but we have other teams at chapter who
work was really extensive legacy code
bases that no one entirely understands
anymore and in those cases they're kind
of slowly working to build test coverage
by writing tests on the pieces as you
work with them so if I am need to add
something to this little piece of the
code base I'm gonna add tests for that
little piece of the code base as I work
on it instead of sitting down and trying
to test this enormous monolith so they
don't really understand
and then this is a super vague guideline
and I'm upfront about that but right
test as early as you feel like they are
invaluable so in a data science workflow
oftentimes we start out in notebooks we
do some exploratory work we play around
with stuff it's not super fixed writing
unit tested that stage is not really
useful but you don't want to sit down
with a system that is about to be
deployed to some production
infrastructure and say oh but I need to
write tests because at that point it's
still useful for the future but you
missed out on a lot of benefits along
the way so a good rule of thumb that we
use your mileage may vary is to kind of
as you start pulling things into
functions and pulling things in the
classes and organizing your code into
libraries it's a really good time to
start writing unit tests - okay so now
we have kind of the idea of unit tests
how do we actually write them so PI test
is one testing framework for Python
there are many many of them are good I
like best because it's both highly
configurable it's super flexible and
there's very little boilerplate so it's
also super simple to get started with
and this is like it does the balance of
those two really nicely my team will
also tell you that I get really excited
when I get these like green lines to
appear on my screen if you write a bunch
of tests you will learn that - this is a
bit of a side note but if you are using
PI test these are super helpful flags
for a PI test that help you get a lot
more useful information out of the test
runner so this is more for reference if
you're interested but super helpful
okay so now we know something about unit
tests we have a framework let's write
some code so we have this super useful
function that adds a column to a pandas
dataframe all of my functions that I'm
testing in this talk are not functions I
would actually advocate that you write
because they are extraordinarily simple
but they kind of show they're just gonna
give us a thing that we can test to
mimic some of the patterns that you see
in data science work so we have this add
column function we have a data frame we
have a column name we have a default
value for this column name and then
we're gonna make a new column and assign
it that done cool no this is our first
unit test so this is an example of a
high test unit test it's just a Python
function we're gonna give our function a
name it's gonna start with test
underscore which is gonna let PI test
find our tests so pi test does really
sweet test discovery like a lot of the
testing frameworks do where if you name
your tests in a consistent manner when
you just run high tests it'll go and
find them all for you and run them all
for you we're then going to define the
input to the function that we want to
test so in this case we're setting up a
data frame we're gonna call the function
that we want to test we're going to set
the expected value but we think we
should get out of this function and then
we're gonna check that the value that we
got was the value that we expected super
simple this pattern this kind of setup
calling the function setting what you
expect to happen and then asserting that
what you expected to happen actually
happened is basically the pattern that
all of your unit tests are going to
follow they're gonna get more
complicated but this same structure is a
good way to think about the pattern okay
so we tested our super simple function
we know that it works that's awesome
let's now make our tests a little
simpler
and give us some tools to expand
to test a bunch more things went I got
fixtures so fixtures are a special type
of function that high test keeps track
of in order to let you safely share
resources and definitions of resources
across tests this may sound a little
vague we're gonna give some examples in
a moment
if you've used other testing frameworks
before they're basically a really
modular way to do setup and teardown
methods so this is defining a couple of
new fixtures you will recognize these
data frames that we just defined in the
test before we have a data frame called
DF sorry we have a function called DF
which returns a data frame and we have a
function called DF with column D that
returns another data frame that has a
column D so we have this normal Python
function that returns a value it can do
whatever kind of stuff you want a Python
function to do sorry and then we have a
decorator that tells PI tests that this
is indeed a fixture there are a couple
of ways that you can get PI tests to
find your fixtures if you define
fixtures in the same file as your tests
it will just find them that's fine as
you get larger and larger test Suites
that gets more and more complicated and
as usual you want to start separating
stuff out into different files we often
have a fixtures file or folder depending
on how large a library we're talking
about and then you have this contest PI
file which is part of PI test setup that
you import all of your fixtures into and
then PI tests knows that these all these
fixtures exists and we can do cool stuff
with them now
so now I'm gonna write it test using
these fixtures you will notice that this
test is very similar to the test that we
did a few moments ago except it now it
looks way simpler so we have these two
arguments to our tests now you will
notice that these the names of these
arguments match the names of the
functions on the other side this is not
my accident and this is important
because PI tests says okay I have this
argument to this test I'm gonna go and
look at all of my fixtures I'm gonna see
if I have a fixture with that name if I
do in this case we do we found this DF
fixture we're gonna run this function
execute any code in it and we're gonna
return the value that this function
returns and funnel it into this variable
that is an argument to the function so
when you call when you call this test
case on the right you get an argument
that's a date that's called DF that
contains this data frame with columns a
B and C similarly the same thing happens
with DF with call T and this data frame
gets passed into the function as well
and so all of our setup work in this
test has now been pulled out into these
fixtures and all we need to do is call
the function and make assertions that we
care about this is super useful in that
it lets you use the same data sup across
multiple tests if you were to try to do
this with just like global variables or
something you run into all sorts of
complications where you try to edit
something and you change it and now your
next test gets a different value and you
can either break things or think that
things are working when they're not
super easily that way so fixtures are
super nice safe way to handle all that
without having to worry about those
dependencies
there are also built-in fixtures that
high-test comes with then some of these
are kind of esoteric things you're not
like who do you use that much and some
of them are really useful caps this is
one that I use a fair amount it is a
fixture that exists that captures
everything written to standard out or
standard error during the execution of
your test and if you give caps as' as a
variable to your function remember PI
test will look at that variable say okay
this variable is called cap sis I'm
gonna go look for a cap sis fixture okay
I have one so I'm going to capture
everything that is set to standard out
or standard error and I'm gonna return
it in this variable or this object and
then you can do this readout error
function so in this test example
function one is literally just a
function that prints out inside function
one and here we can assert that that is
in fact what is happening this is often
helpful if you have kind of modeling
jobs that print out debugging stuff in
them like print out information about
what's happening this is a good way to
verify that you're printing out the
things that you think you are which may
not feel feels super critical to the
functionality of what's happening but is
super critical to understanding the that
the things that you are using to debug
your code are actually real another
useful side note you can run high test -
- fixtures will list out all of the
available fixtures so this includes the
fixtures that PI test defines itself as
well as any that you have defined in
your own code with their doctrines so
just a nice way to check that
everything's being pulled together the
way you think it is
cool so we have to find some fixtures
but we do find super simple ones
fixtures in and of themselves are
actually really flexible you can do all
kinds of stuff with them the kind of
most basic thing to do is to just return
on value like we did with the data
frames a couple slides ago but they can
actually do way more stuff than that so
you can define the scope of a fixture so
this means that the your fixture
function might be run by default is run
at the start of every test but you can
also define it so it's only run at the
start of every session or every class or
a different bunch of different levels
you can compose fixture so you can have
fixtures that depend on other fixtures
you can execute custom teardown code
when the fixture leaves the scope so you
can have a fixture that needs to be torn
down at the end of a test and have that
all happen automatically so this is the
teardown side of the setup and teardown
methods
you can also access the kind of text
context when you're in the fixture
basically this is a way to let you pass
parameters from a test to fixtures and
then you can actually parameterize the
fixtures to depend on different
variables
it may not be obvious why you want to do
many of these things but there cases
where they're useful this is one case
where they're useful we read a lot of
theis part code a trap runner so we then
want to write tests for this code we
want to run the tests on a single
machine we don't want to spin up a spark
cluster to run our tests so you can
define a local spark session which is
what we're doing right here and this is
also then showing several of the
flexibility features that I just
mentioned so we're defining the scope
the scope of this fixture is the session
so that means when you run PI tests
everything that happens after that is
one test session so what this does is
it's going to create a spark session and
then it's gonna run all of my tests in
it and then it's gonna tear down the
spark session this is useful because it
takes a while to spin up
session so you don't really want to do
it look forward after every single one
of your tests because then you spend
most of your time creating and
destroying SPARC sessions and very
little of your time actually testing
your code so I've talked about accessing
the test context that's what this
request argument is so the request
argument sends a bunch of information
about what's happening in the test case
to the fixture and then the fixture can
access it like it's happening here with
this request add finalizer which is one
way there are a couple to add custom
teardown code so this says that when I
exit this scope so in this case my scope
is a session so when I'm done with the
testing session I'm gonna call spark dot
stop and that stops the spark session so
I don't just you know have a spark
session running and terminate on my
computer so this is a one example of
like a thing then we want to do a lot
that is really easy in this in this
setup because of the flexibility of
these problem fixtures one other thing I
mentioned is dependencies so if we're
testing spark code we're gonna want
fixtures that instead of being pandas
dataframes our spark data frames so but
in order to create a spark data frame I
need a spark session so this is a
another fixture that depends on the
first fixture so it takes the spark
session defined in the first fixture and
it uses it to create a data frame that
it then returns so then I can reference
this spark the a fixture in my tests and
be good to go so fixtures do a whole
bunch of things if you need to set
something up and you're not sure how to
do it definitely go look at fixture dots
because they do all sorts of crazy
things that I had no idea they would do
when I got started another super useful
tool that you may have heard of is
mocking so mocking is like a general
idea that's used in all sorts of kind of
programming languages
the name of the library in Python that
does mocking for Python so some Python
specific and some not there so we're
gonna talk about we're gonna give a
given example here just think about why
we might want to mock sings so I met
everybody in this room has read from a
database in Python code before it's a
thing that we do all the time because
our data often lives in databases and we
might have a function that looks like
this
so I wrote a super general generate
features function take some credentials
do some stuff then I'm going to create a
sequel alchemy engine and pass it to
read panda's read sequel function if
you're not familiar with this set up
it's basically just a way to connect to
a database and execute a sequel query
and get a data frame back and then I'm
gonna do some processing on that data
frame generate some features return this
features function so this is one snippet
in a larger function and I want to be
able to test this function I want to
know that my future generation code is
doing the right things but when I'm
running my tests I don't want to
actually access the database maybe I'm
running them in a different setup right
can't actually connect to the database
maybe I just don't want to touch
production servers from my laptop
because that's scary all sorts of things
so we want to be able to get rid of this
so just like checkout out of the way
this database access so we want to
replace this connection with like a fake
thing so it looks like a connection but
doesn't it actually connect to anything
and then we want to be able to return
some data from this read sequel function
because if we don't actually return
anything then the rest of the code is
gonna fail we don't want that we want to
know what happens in the rest of the
code but we when I just kind of
short-circuit as somehow so this is what
Marco's you do
so this is a test using mock there are a
couple of pieces here that are doing
some interesting things so you will
notice these mock dot patch decorators
on this function patch is a method of
mock of like a function in mock that
does this short-circuiting part so it's
it goes and finds the place in the code
we're using this function that you don't
want to actually use and it sticks
something else in there instead and then
there are mock objects as well that
usually is the thing you stick in and
we're gonna talk a little bit more about
mock objects in a moment but this mock
dot patch essentially goes and grabs
this create engine function and this
reads equal function sticks this mock
object in its place and then I can call
my generate features function and as it
runs through it instead of actually
accessing the database it's going to
make those same calls to these mock
objects instead which aren't going to do
anything except what I tell them to so I
have said here I have this read sequel
mock we're going to talk more about the
logistics of how all of this gets passed
through in a moment so don't worry too
much about the details but I'm setting a
return value here as a data frame so
this means that when I call this mock
which is going to happen because it got
patched into place instead of not having
anything to return because it didn't
actually talk to the database I've given
it this data frame to return so now I
can run my test and my tests can run
generate features and now it has a data
frame to play with and I can make sure
that the actual features that my
generated feature function return' are
the features that I would expect given
DF as the input data frame as like the
input data
so we talk a little bit of the specific
mock objects we have this really awesome
mock stuffed animal over there and so a
mock object is a funky thing it's just a
fake object but you can stick in a spot
that does basically two things and
that's let you get rid and and the point
of those things is just to let you cut
out dependencies so we talked about unit
testing being testing things in
isolation and this is a really powerful
tool to isolate things in complicated
systems so things you might want to mock
as we just talked about database reads
and writes probably don't to actually do
that during testing so you can mock them
away API calls probably don't to
actually call the api's so you can mock
them away and then just in general
external functions that you don't care
about testing that aren't part of this
one specific piece of functionality that
you are currently trying to test so
often you will have a system where you
will mock part of it away while you're
testing this piece and then in the next
test you're gonna test this piece and
mock the first piece away so it doesn't
mean that you're never gonna test this
piece of code but it's not relevant to
the current thing that we're trying to
understand
so unit test up mock these pythons unit
testing library it's part of standard
Lib in Python 3 if it's if you're using
Python 2 don't but also you can import
mock as a library from from pi PI it's
back ported to Python 2 as well so
pythons mock library has a variety of
mock objects in it but almost always
what you want is the default magic mock
object and these objects think of an
interesting ways you can alter their
behavior in a bunch of ways but by
default they accept any call that's made
to them any attribute access any method
access they don't throw any errors no
matter what kind of call you make on
them and every time you make any sort of
call the return value of that call is a
new magic mock object and similarly
anytime you access an attribute of a
magic mock object what you get that
attribute is created as a new magic mock
object and then all of these magic mock
objects record everything that happens
to them so each magic mock object
records any call that's made to it and
the arguments of that call so they're
really useful for assertions done so
this is just me playing around inter
apple with magic mock objects if you're
not familiar with these objects if you
haven't used them a lot I highly
recommend this exercise of just trying a
bunch of things seeing what gives you
errors seeing what return values are
it's super useful to just get a sense
for what happens because it's not very
intuitive they're very strange objects
so the details of what I'm doing here
are less important than just kind of
this idea that it's really useful to
play around with a little bit so I
object doing kind of two things one of
the things that mock objects do is they
like provide actions they have they
return stuff when you call them as we
just said by default they return new
magic mock objects but it's not always
what you want right I like in the
database read function that we just
talked about we wanted to actually
return a data frame because we wanted to
know what would happen to that data
frame and the rest of the function so
there's a couple of ways to get your
mock to give stuff back the first way is
a method called return value this one's
pretty straightforward you give it you
set a return value and then every time
you call that mock you get that return
value back so if I set my return value
to be a list of three integers
every time I call that mock I get back a
list of three integers then the other
way to get things back is this side
effect method this side effect method is
very unintuitive to me but it's super
useful and you're gonna use a lot there
are kind of three main ways to use it
the first one is the most common so
let's say I have a function that gets
called several times in the function
that I'm testing and I want to mock it
but I want to I need a different return
value every time I call it you do that
with side effects so you consent
side-effect equals any kind of iterable
and then each time you call the function
you get back to the next thing in your
interval so the first time I called this
mock object I would get back first
object the second time I called that
mock object I would get back a second
object and so on another thing you can
do is set the side-effect to be an
exception and then any time you call
this function you will get you it will
throw that exception it will raise that
exception this can be useful for testing
error handling paths in your code
I don't use it all that often but that's
that's one thing it's useful for then
this next one so these are all side
effects it's the method for all of these
it does a couple different things the
last thing it does is you can set it to
be another function if you set your
side-effect method to be a function then
every time this mock object is called
the side-effect function is also called
with the same arguments given to the
call to the mock object and then if that
throws an error if there was an error if
it doesn't it returns the return value
so here I have a lambda function that
checks if that takes one variable and
checks if that variable is even or odd
and this is just some modular math if
you're not familiar and just returns the
string odd or even depending on whether
the int given was is odd or even
so now after setting the side-effect if
I call this mock object with one
argument that's the integer one I get
back a string that said it's odd if I
call it with the integer xx I'll get
back a string that says even if I call
it with three integers I'm gonna get an
error because that doesn't match this
the signature of the side-effect method
this is the functions are easy to do
weird things with I only ever used them
to do very happy things that I would not
really recommend but they can be useful
in certain cases okay so this is a bunch
of actions that you're mocking take the
things that your mock can do in a test
function the other thing that we care
about is the assertions that we can make
on the mock objects when we're done with
the test so you mock some stuff you
patch it into your the functions that
you're trying to test you run your
function that you want to test and then
you have these mock objects that have
recorded everything that's happened to
them in the tests and so sometimes you
care
whether or not something happened to
them so a good example here is if you're
mocking alright to a database you might
well want to mock so you do want to mock
that right and then you will want to
assert that you wrote the thing you
intended to write so you want to check
that whatever your right database
function is got called with the data
frame that you are intending to write to
that database so there's all kinds of
assertion methods this is a small subset
of them so you can assert that a mock
was called at all you could assert that
it was called exactly ones you can
assert that it was called a certain
arguments you will also sometimes get
into cases where the precise thing that
you want to assert is not one of these
methods and in that case this call args
list method is super useful because it
gives you back a list of all of the
calls made to that object and then you
can do whatever person on them whatever
checking you want to do so with a little
less clean but a lot more flexible one
morning
you weren't enough be weary of typos
here
remember that mocks accept any call made
to them with very few exceptions so this
first case assert called once is a real
mock method ascertain that will check if
that mock was called once and if it was
then it passes if it's not throws an
exception this next one maybe I forgot
exactly what this interface was what
this API was and I called mock dot
called once this is not a method that
exists in mocks library but it's not
gonna throw an exception because mocks
accept all calls made to them so you
will instead get back a magic mock
object it will continue on its way which
means your tests will never fail which
means you think you're testing something
but you're actually not testing anything
at all so it's a good thing to be be
wary of
they have in recent releases of mock
made some concessions to this
and they've made it so that any method
starting with assert if it's not
actually an assertion will throw an
error so if you're bad at type in like I
am and you call a method assert called
but you spell it wrong then that will
throw an error so they've started to
help it you out a little bit but it's
still something to be wary of mocs also
have some like particular gotchas one is
where to patch an object so when you
call Mach that patch you give it a
string that's a path of Python
essentially Python imports but it's not
what you think it's going to be if
you're not used to this framework and if
you don't think super carefully about
how Python imports work so if I want to
mock panda like pandas not read CSV call
in my function I might think that the
second way is the way to do that I want
to mock pandas read CSV so I'm gonna
call mock on this string pandas dot read
CSV that's not gonna work
instead you have to mock the object
where it's used not where it's defined
so in this first case in the with the
green check mark here I have a module
called PI test examples a file called
functions to test in functions to test I
import pandas as PD and then somewhere
in that file
I say PD read CSV so at the point in
time where mock can stick my mock object
in where it's supposed to be
um pandas can replace these objects I'm
sorry I am overtime I apologize the
other mod is important the other Gacha
is import order you can pay attention to
these things in a future moment these
it's a it's a good thing to check out
the the order of your mocs is opposite
of what you think it should be when you
patch things though these last are just
a couple of resources these are a couple
of useful libraries you should check out
and then these are some useful blog
posts to read this bitly link contains
up further and mark sense of list and
this is a link to the repo that has all
of these examples and will also have
these life later on qualities from
running over if you have any questions
talk to you later
[Applause]